e
[Musique]
La Malaisie est une fédération de 13 États en
Asie du Sud-Est. 11 sont situés sur la
péninsule occidentale et deux à l'est sur
l'île de Bornéo. Notre aventure est
centrée sur la péninsule de la
mer de Chine et commence dans un petit village appelé
pantti.  sabak dans l'état du
kentan au lever du soleil le jeune Zer rupi est
déjà au travail il va pêcher avec
ses deux frères père grand-père et
oncle aujourd'hui est un jour crucial car la
saison de pêche touche à sa fin et
les derniers jours n'ont pas été très  Le
père de Zar rupi, Yakub,
a commencé à pêcher à l'âge de 12 ans. Il a
maintenant
47 ans. Son bateau aux couleurs vives avec sa
proue sculptée lui a été offert par son
père [
Musique]
Yakub et la famille de Zer rupi font partie d'
une équipe composée de 30 personnes.  pêcheurs et
cinq bateaux les pêcheurs de sabac sont
célèbres en Malaisie pour leur esprit d'équipe
et leurs valeurs de partage et d'entraide
cet esprit particulier en
Malaisie s'appelle gong
[Musique]
le long
du poteau dans l'eau révèle la
présence d'un
récif artificiel Le Récif  a été immergé il y a quelques années à
plusieurs kilomètres des
côtes elle a développé des coraux et des
colonies de poissons de tailles et d'
espèces variées La Malaisie a depuis immergé
près de 300 de ces récifs artificiels le long de
ses
côtes les pêcheurs de sabac en profitent
et ont mis au point une
méthode de pêche unique  le salaun un petit
poisson ressemblant au maquereau
[Musique]
ils commencent par tester la quantité de
salak cooning à l'aide d'une ligne à nombreux
hameçons appelée Apollo lorsque le test est
concluant la pêche peut
commencer quatre des cinq bateaux descendent un filet de
plusieurs centaines de mètres de longueur  à une
profondeur de 30 à 40 m à une certaine distance
de The Reef le cinquième bateau, le
vaisseau amiral est transporté vers les autres et
se dirige vers le
récif [Musique] L'étape suivante consiste à laisser tomber une
série de branches de palmiers dans l'
eau alourdies par  Des pierres elles
descendent progressivement vers le fond du
récif ces branches sont en fait un piège
que les malais appellent un
unang deux plongeurs se lancent en
action leur rôle est d'orienter le
mouvement des poissons vers les
branches qu'ils attirent les plus curieux
en tapotant sur le  l'eau cela
leur montrera qu'il y a plus de
[Musique]
en bas à l'aide des cordages le vaisseau amiral est
tiré progressivement à la main vers les
autres
bateaux sans ces cordages les forts
courants les sépareraient rapidement
les branches avec leur population
de poissons sont progressivement amenées vers
l'eau  filet quand les plongeurs sont sûrs que
les poissons sont en place ils font
savoir
qu'il y a très peu de temps avant que la
marée monte et que les courants
[Musique]
changent l'équipe sur le vaisseau amiral
retire rapidement les branches de l'eau et fait
signe à  les autres pour remonter le
filet ils doivent se dépêcher du centre de
la zone de pêche pour éviter que leur
hélice ne se prenne dans le
filet
le filet est tiré par les pêcheurs
des quatre bateaux qui se poussent
petit à petit ils  réduire le
périmètre en opposant leurs forces à contre-
courant la dernière prise a été décevante
avec à peine cinq ou six casiers pour chaque
bateau ce n'était certainement rien d'
extraordinaire pour nos 30
marins [Musique] sur les derniers mètres le filet
n'est tenu que par deux  bateaux pendant que les
trois autres attendent derrière pour voir le
résultat
l'un après l'autre les paniers sont
hissés hors du filet les
poissons encore frétillants sont répartis à parts égales
entre les cinq bateaux et jetés dans les
casiers
un peu de glace est ajoutée pour conserver le
poisson jusqu'à ce que  ils rentrent au
port la première prise est plutôt
bonne chaque bateau remplit deux
casiers les pêcheurs décident alors de continuer
et tenter leur vie sur un autre récif la
mer est calme et le temps est
dégagé M à un pylône au dessus du récif le vaisseau
amiral  trouve un
banc de poissons particulièrement grand la même procédure est
effectuée rapidement
les branches du Yun Jang sont
jetées puis retirées
le filet peut à nouveau être
relevé cette fois il est extrêmement
lourd
le spectacle sous-marin fascine
des centaines et des milliers de poissons  sont
piégés et la mer regorge d'une
multitude d'écailles
[Musique]
chatoyantes
ce n'est que maintenant que les pêcheurs
réalisent combien ils en ont
attrapé le filet est un tapis blanc de
poissons argentés le chef du groupe distribue volontiers
les
paniers et 25 casiers supplémentaires sont
ajoutée aux 10 précédentes la prise d'aujourd'hui
est exceptionnelle près d'une tonne de poisson pour
cinq bateaux en une seule
matinée
il est midi passé yakub et ses fils
se dirigent vers
[Musique]
Port les bateaux s'alignent dans le petit
canal qui mène au port de sabak
ils sont Chargés de casiers de poissons
particulièrement salak
kuning
les poissons sont déchargés et triés par
yakob sa femme et ses fils ils seront ensuite
vendus au marché de kotab Bahu la
Ville voisine
en tout nous sommes six dans la famille pour aller
pêcher tous
les matins et  à notre retour nous partageons nos
gains plus nous travaillons avec de bateaux
plus nous ramenons de poissons et plus
nous
gagnons d'argent comme tous les pêcheurs ici nous ne
pêchons pas pendant la saison de mousson entre
novembre décembre à février
mars donc pendant 3 mois nous devons
vivre  sans aucun
revenu
oui et est-ce trop dangereux de sortir en
mer pendant la
mousson c'est non seulement dangereux c'est
interdit tu peux être
arrêté je ne prendrais pas le risque non plus
la mer est dangereuse pendant la
mousson oui c'est dangereux le bateau  ça
risque de chavirer les marins peuvent tomber
à l'eau et je finirais en
prison oui en prison la
pêche est dangereuse ici il y a deux ou 3 semaines
j'ai été pourchassé par un requin alors que j'étais
dans l'
eau oui c'était proche
rien de grave  cela s'est produit
jusqu'à
présent et j'espère que cela restera
[Musique]
tout au fond de la jungle à Tasik
dans l'état de Pahang, on peut rencontrer les
plus anciens habitants de la
péninsule malaisienne 1 400 aborigènes des
groupes ethniques
samal tasik bira est un labyrinthe de
rivières  et des lacs couvrant près de 7 000
hectares ici la végétation et la faune
sont à la fois vastes et
diversifiées il y a environ 200
espèces d'oiseaux et près de 100 espèces
de mammifères et les rep
Iles et coq sa femme Guya et leur
famille vivent du milieu naturel
la forêt et ses hévéas  la
rivière et ses poissons aujourd'hui ils vont
pêcher avec leur belle-fille
janeri et leur petit-fils
bin
les rivières et les lacs de beera sont
peuplés de plus de 90
espèces différentes de poissons la plupart sont des carpes silures
Barbons hampas et autres
[Musique]
tomans  fr coq pêche avec un harpon sur
le bord de la berge
après plusieurs averses le niveau de l'eau
a rapidement monté rendant la pêche
difficile et
imprévisible enock trouve un petit
poisson-chat dans les herbes il le lance d'
un coup de lance
speee
enok prend un piège en bambou  de l'eau
qu'il a laissé là il y a quelques jours alors qu'il
sort le poisson guya coupe un morceau de
[Musique] igname
continue En aval les quatre
pêcheurs ont vérifié les autres pièges à poissons
placés là il y a quelques jours en Malaisie c'est ce qu'on
appelle Boo
Boo  les poissons sont attirés par les morceaux d'
igname placés un à un dans le Piège les
poissons sont retirés et l'igname est soit
remis soit remplacé si besoin aujourd'hui c'est
un jour pour le
poisson-chat
en voici deux
autres le Piège est ensuite remis à la
rivière
les petits  bin ne sera pas en reste il
apporte fièrement à sa mère son boo boo
contenant un petit
poisson selon la saison les semai
pêchent les crabes ou
les tortues
ils doivent toujours se méfier des serpents
et crocodiles qui peuplent les lacs
marécages et rivières de task
B pour guya  la pêche se termine toujours par une
baignade dans la
rivière [Musique] la fin d'un après-midi paisible
elle rapporte du poisson à sa famille pour
accompagner le
repas du soir sur la côte est de la péninsule
il y a beaucoup à offrir aux visiteurs de passage
sur l'île de Redang en  l'
état de
[Musique]
terenu
les gens de Redang vivent encore en grande partie
de la pêche ils ont beaucoup amélioré la
technique ancestrale du piégeage que l'on
vient de voir avec les samai du tasik
bira ici ils sont aussi appelés
bobos Muhammad Nordin et ses deux
complices sont partis 10  boo boo 40 m de fond il y a
quelques jours près de l'île aux requins aujourd'hui
ils sont venus les récupérer
une fois le boo boo vidé il est
inspecté et si besoin réparé puis
remis sur le
fond marin il est signalé aux propriétaires par un
[Rires]
garçon  le fond marin est composé de roches de sable
et de corail il est riche d'une grande
variété de vivaneaux blancs cobas travali carpe
thon maquereau ainsi que des requins et des
méduses géantes lentement lentement lentement
lentement
les poissons entrent par l'
ouverture en forme d'entonnoir sur le côté de  le grand piège
une fois à l'intérieur, attiré par des poissons plus petits ou
des algues, ils ont peu de chance de
s'échapper en fonction du poisson. Les Malaisiens
construisent plusieurs types de bobos de
différentes tailles et ouvertures à l'aide de
cordes et de câbles en bois de bambou avec lesquels
les trois membres de l'équipage travaillent avec
précision les courants autour de l'île.
rendre difficile la réalisation de cette tâche
car les cages peuvent être coincées entre les rochers
ou les coraux sur le
fond marin
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la prise a été bonne Muhammad est
heureux les Boo Boos sont retournés dans les
profondeurs pour quelques jours de plus
[Musique] le
poisson est  la source de protéines préférée
des Malaisiens musulmans attirés par la
mer ils en consomment près de 50 kilos par
an et par habitant un million et demi de
tonnes de poissons et fruits de mer sont pêchés en
Malaisie chaque
année
une scène étonnante se déroule chaque
matin à Bess près de Quanan quand  les
bateaux reviennent avec une nouvelle envie il
faut vite les décharger et les amener
à l'étuve dans cette
optique les villageois utilisent deux
buffles dociles et bienveillants ils ne craignent
ni l'eau salée ni la
corrosion
hé
les anchois sont soigneusement bouillis et
[Musique]
égouttés  puis ils sont disposés devant
le village sur de grands bambous où
ils sont séchés pendant plusieurs
jours.
[Musique]
Rivière, mer et pêche sont l'essence de la
vie sur la péninsule. La Malaisie est un
pays de contrastes mais riche de
traditions il est aussi résolument dessiné.
vers
la modernité aujourd'hui le tassi Kenya représente le mieux la
Malaisie et l'importance
que les malaisiens ont accordé à la
pêche sportive A 55 km de quala tangu Le Kenya est
un lac tentaculaire de 260 000 hectares et
îles il a été créé en 1985 par la
construction du barrage qui porte le
même  Kener est le plus grand
lac artificiel d'Asie du Sud-Est
au cœur de cet
environnement exceptionnel. Les Malaisiens viennent
se détendre le temps d'un week-end et s'adonner à
diverses activités nautiques et de plein air.
Adrien et ses amis Raheim
et Nazmi vont à la pêche sportive
[Musique]
aujourd'hui.  ils nous emmènent au cœur de la
jungle à Tamama Negara à la recherche des
plus belles espèces du Kenya le Toman le
sebarau et le Kayla
en se dirigeant vers Tamara ils tombent
sur une péniche remarquable où il est
possible pour 10 pêcheurs de travailler jour
et nuit en changeant de site à
volonté
[Musique]
plus nous nous enfonçons dans les
méandres du lac, plus
le paysage
devient saisissant. Le Kenya est un paradis pour les pêcheurs.
[Musique]
Nous arrivons enfin au
parc national de Tamama Nagara, sur la rive sud
du lac, un secteur où  ça reste
sauvage mais
préservé la jungle ici a 40 millions d'
années en cette saison particulière il
faut aller pêcher En amont où
40 rivières se jettent dans le
lac edin et Nasi continuent ainsi dans un
petit bateau qui est moins encombrant qu'un
hors-bord et un  beaucoup plus discret A
l'approche d'espèces qui s'effrayent facilement,
ils tentent d'abord leur chance au milieu
d'une forêt immergée souvent considérée comme
le meilleur site de pêche car les racines peuvent
offrir une multitude de
cachettes ils n'y parviennent pas alors nos
amis décident d'aller plus loin.  creuser
plus profondément là où vivent tigre éléphant loutre cerf
tapier ours et
singe edin et Nasi utilisent des cannes fastaction
et une ligne légère 20b cela donne au poisson une
meilleure chance et le rend d'autant plus
sportif cette ligne particulière est
essentielle pour éviter qu'elle ne se brise lorsque le
poisson accroché  Plonge derrière des branches de rochers
ou
Roots Edin a accroché son premier poisson il
essaie de l'empêcher de passer sous le
bateau [Musique] a [
Musique] [
Musique]
c'est un toan un poisson carnivore qui mange
tout sur son passage tu ferais bien de
évitez de laisser vos doigts ou vos orteils sur
son passage
[Musique]
c'est le serpent géant de Malaisie headit
toan avec son corps long et sa tête en forme de serpent
il porte le nom approprié de
tête de serpent celui-ci pèse
environ 1 kilo
maintenant c'est au tour de nasm il est accro  un
poisson argenté qui se bat comme un
vrai diable c'est un hampala de la
famille des cyprinidés les malais l'appellent
[Musique]
sebero on le reconnaît à sa
bande noire verticale sous la
nageoire dorsale il se nourrit essentiellement de petits poissons
mais aussi d'insectes vers et de crevettes  le
plus gros peut atteindre 4 kilos ou
plus la seber ale n'est peut-être pas le
plus gros poisson malaisien mais c'est
certainement l'un des plus difficiles à
attraper c'est un poisson fort puissant
gueule puissante voyez-le mâchoire puissante
Édenté Édenté mais très fort la
mâchoire est très forte vous  peut écraser euh les
hameçons les hameçons triples pas de
problème edin et Nasi chaque hameçon un seow
évidemment un groupe a choisi de vivre dans
ce coude de la rivière ils doivent
lâcher les plus petits
[Musique]
oh
juste quelques secondes après avoir pris le  dernier searo
hors de l'eau, la canne de nasm commence à
siffler et se précipite jusqu'au
point de rupture, le poisson plonge au fond du lit de
la rivière en essayant de se libérer en
brisant la ligne sur les racines et
[Musique]
les roches nzm doivent l'enrouler rapidement s'il
veut  éviter de le perdre
[Musique]
gros poisson gros
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
poisson Nasi a accroché un bon siiz toan
qu'il enroule avec beaucoup de dextérité dans
l'épuisette tenue par
edin ce monstre carnivore d'eau douce
peut atteindre jusqu'à 20 kilos et  1 m de
long peut vérifier les
dents qu'il brise violemment sur les poissons morts et
les leurres, mais seulement lorsqu'il a faim ou est en colère.
De plus en plus de pêcheurs sportifs viennent en Asie
pour se mesurer à ce
monstre.
[Musique]
on peut pêcher jusqu'à 300 espèces différentes  Le
lac Kenya et les rivières qui
l'alimentent en plus du Toman et du Sear, il
y a maintenant le poisson-chat géant gurami Bas C et le
brochet malaisien [Musique] [Musique]
après un dernier toan, nos deux pêcheurs
décident de rejoindre le reste de l'
équipe [Musique]
qu'as-tu attrapé aujourd'hui oh la prise
était très bonne c'est que nous avons eu en fait nous
avons beaucoup de maison Sabara ici puis
toan pour aujourd'hui nous avons essayé le lancer d'appâts
avec des appâts artificiels, des coups rouges qui sont les
beit les plus efficaces de
KY euh ils l'appellent Ultram  mec,
comme vous pouvez le voir, c'est tout nouveau
et j'ai quelques marques de Toan ici,
quelques marques de Toman et celle-ci aussi peut voir
les marques de dents sur l'
homme, c'est la dernière euh que je
teste, euh, un hangar de coureur peu profond enveloppe
ça  euh la couleur macel est belle et
elle attrape beaucoup de poissons le premier Stan j'ai
attrapé le petit, j'utilisais celui-ci,
tu peux pratiquer beaucoup de techniques
ici à K Lake et l'autre chose que nous
avons euh immense endroit immense emplacement pour
pêcher
ici  il est très difficile d'attraper le CLA
et la règle générale est de rester silencieux, sans
bruit du tout, puis de ne pas se déplacer
d'une rive à l'autre, de ne
créer aucun mouvement que vous voyez et
la troisième est de porter des vêtements de couleurs sombres,
surtout euh quand  vous êtes près
des rochers vous avez vous pouvez vous mettre à
l'
arrière-plan c'est le principal, car ici
c'est le siège Palm c'est très
efficace sur CLA le meilleur endroit pour attraper
CLA est euh
en amont et vous avez besoin d'une eau claire et profonde
et et j'ai  ici avec moi que mon
ami là-bas a attrapé celui-ci pendant que
nous étions occupés à
lancer un petit spécimen de Kala T
tamro Des Malayan Kala [
Musique] la
pêche au gros est relativement nouvelle sur les
côtes malaisiennes les bateaux sont généralement de
vieux bateaux de pêche traditionnels convertis
pour le
mais comme au Kenya, Edin et ses
amis Nazmi et Rahim sont encore une fois
nos guides. Ils pêchent généralement dans les
eaux autour de l'
île de Redang. La pêche dans ces eaux nécessite beaucoup
de connaissances
et d'expérience si vous connaissez de bons
sports et techniques provenant d'autres régions
de la Malaisie.  c'est différent c'est totalement
différent sur l'île de Rang il
y a peu de gros poissons dans la
mer de Chine méridionale le tombant du plateau continental
est loin de la côte et il faudrait
plusieurs jours pour
l'atteindre mais on peut quand même trouver
parmi eux une grande variété de poissons de taille moyenne
le makaire noir agressif qui pèse
entre 40 et 150 kilos et le
poisson voilier qui pèse de 20 à 60 kilos il
y a aussi de nombreux bancs de
dauphins géants travali ainsi que le
Barracuda waho thon et les vivaneaux
criard
criard ce poisson s'appelle IM sympa
manger des poissons poissons  en Malaisie, ils sont
difficiles à attraper, ils sont si intelligents que
même certains pêcheurs internationaux sont
venus avec leurs matériels de haute technologie,
mais ils n'ont toujours pas attrapé le
bon poisson, ils ont vu des poissons, vous
connaissez le poisson qu'ils veulent, comme Malin qui
joue et ils  essayé et essayé
essayer et essayer ils abandonnent c'est un vrai
défi
ici
une coryphène ce que les Malaisiens appellent
un Dorado est l'un des
poissons pélagiques les plus colorés un nageur impressionnant il
peut atteindre 80 km/h et peser jusqu'à 20
kilos dont il se nourrit  poissons volants et
seiches edin a accroché une
femelle, ils se différencient facilement
des mâles par leurs têtes plus rondes
ouais, je
n'en ai pas
[Musique]
ce Dorado c'est l'île de Redang Dorado
excellent manger du poisson bon pour faire du fish
and
chips mon poisson préféré qui devrait
être cela devrait certainement être Marin noir
Marin pourquoi à part le
travali géant GT ou
les thons parce que Marin ils sont vraiment
différents des autres poissons par rapport aux
thons. Les thons ont des stamas, ils sont
puissants mais Malin ils ont du caractère
parfois le plus jeune se bat plus fort
que  les 50 kilos ou plus qu'ils vous donnent, ils
vous donnent un combat plus long
et une fois le poisson élevé, oh, c'est
juste un petit poisson, c'est pourquoi les gens
chassent le Marin dans le monde entier juste pour savoir
quelle est la
différence [Musique] avec la Chine du Sud  La mer est un
passage entre le Pacifique et l'
Océan Indien pour la migration des
marlins noirs on les trouve souvent autour des
îles ou dans les failles proches des côtes
on peut les attraper à la traîne avec des
appâts vivants ou des leurres en Malaisie comme les autres
istiophoridés dont ils sont protégés.
et en général
[Music]
a sorti le hit Mal, j'ai frappé mon morceau et mon
ballon a
éclaté et tout s'est déchaîné parce que tout le
monde n'était pas préparé, vous savez, tout
le monde dormait en attendant 3
heures sans action et puis tout à coup,
ce cri euh fort est sorti de ma
bobine.
J'ai estimé que c'était un gros gros
poisson mais ça n'a pris qu'une demi-
heure à 45 minutes même
si j'utilisais une ligne de 25 lb, je
m'assure d'avoir beaucoup de ligne euh 1 000 M à
700 M de  ligne dans mon moulinet juste pour
m'assurer qu'il y a beaucoup de ligne. J'utilisais
un gros moulinet mais une ligne plus légère donc euh
ça ne l'a pas fait, ça n'a pas fait grand chose de
saut mais beaucoup de plongée
sous-marine, ça va tout droit.
sous le fond et sort pendant un
moment, puis faites quelques courses supplémentaires
en dessous,
d'accord, quand il s'est approché assez près,
nous avons vu l'intestin sortir
de la bouche, donc
euh, c'est mauvais, c'est mauvais quand vous
pêchez au marin.  euh avec l'appâtage de la vie
parce que parfois il accrochera, il
prendra l'appât et l'avalera et vous vous vous vous
trompez en frappant votre canne,
donc euh je, je n'utilisais pas d'
hameçon circulaire à ce moment-là, ce qui est bon pour juste
ça le fera  crochet exactement euh autour de la
bouche du Marin, je n'utilisais pas ce crochet,
j'utilisais euh ces crochets de la vie normale, des
crochets de gorille,
donc nous avons décidé de ne pas évoquer le Marin
parce que c'était si triste de voir que Marin
devait se battre pour lutter pour  éloignez-vous
de la ligne, nous venons de couper la ligne, il suffit de
couper la ligne, de remettre l'intestin
dans la bouche, de commencer à le réanimer,
le bateau bouge plus lentement, il commence à bouger, alors
assurez-vous qu'il ait un peu d'air pour se relancer lorsque l'
eau commence, puis il démarre.  bouger sa
queue comme se débattre, ok, c'est un bon
signe que le Malin va survivre et il n'y a pas
beaucoup de dégâts, juste l'intestin
est dans tout va bien, ça a l'air bien
et la caisse bouge très fort
donc après ça on le laisse et  il
nage très vite donc c'était le plus grand
moment pour lâcher un
Malin
[Musique]
avant de quitter la Malaisie, nous avons pu
vivre une dernière aventure de pêche
qui était vraiment
mémorable
[Musique]
il était une fois un bateau en pleine mer dans
le  belle
nuit malgré l'heure tardive l'
ambiance à bord était très
détendue
[Musique] il
était une fois des poissons et des calamars attirés
par les lumières chatoyantes [
Musique] il
y avait autrefois des pêcheurs qui adoraient
pêcher
la nuit [Musique]
je m'appelle Mustafa  Je viens du
village de penck dans l'état de
terangan Je pêche depuis 5 ans
à l'aide d'un grand filet circulaire appelé pukat
Gerald nous pêchons la nuit car nos
lumières attirent beaucoup de calamars et de poissons certains
sont très
gros quand je pense au  ces 5 dernières années la
pêche est bien meilleure de nuit que
de
jour bien sur la pêche de nuit n'est pas
sans danger on n'est pas toujours à l'
abri des brusques changements de
météo on peut se retrouver au
large en pleine nuit
sans visibilité  et de grosses vagues, mais quand la
lune est levée, généralement, tout va bien et la
pêche est
bonne. Mon moment préféré est celui où nous jetons
les filets et avec la
lumière vacillante du dernier flotteur, nous réalisons que nous
avons une grande quantité de poissons, nous travaillons
plus dur et  tout le monde crie de joie on
sait tous que nous avons passé une bonne
journée
il est 1h du matin après 5 heures à
attirer les poissons vers les lumières deux
flotteurs sont mis à l'eau équipés de
plusieurs
lampes les lumières du bateau sont éteintes
afin de regrouper les poissons autour du
petit bateau pour que le filet puisse être
placé
[Musique]
puis les lumières principales du bateau se rallument
pour équilibrer la densité des poissons
de chaque côté du
filet déjà les pêcheurs commencent à le tirer
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
dans
spee spee étranger
[Musique]
hé [
Musique] [Musique
]
do [
Musique]
il était une fois un bateau avec sa cale
remplie par un pêcheur infatigable avec de l'
âme travali de thon et de maquereau et du
Cobia
[Musique]
comme tous les Malaisiens  sur l'archipel
les 3 millions de pêcheurs professionnels saisonniers ou
sportifs partagent une relation étroite et
passionnée avec les fleuves,
la mer et la vie marine
[Musique]